one of the things I really enjoyed about
developing on android is all the
debugging support that the platform has
especially the fact that the simulator
and the device are actually quite
similar you can issue similar similar
commands to each one there's a trace
view to see how your performances and
there's also the adb shell delao you
install and uninstall your games and as
well as see what processes are running
right now the sound support on Android
is also really good their support for
many different kinds of formats it's
easy to load them up and play them it's
quite responsive so some things I'd like
to see to make Android development a
little bit easier is the ability to
store byte arrays into the shared
preferences and also the ability to
simulate saving and restoring behavior
because the lifecycle is very important
to Android development